From the Pagodas of Myanmar Myanmar to the high rises of Singapore from what were
the killing fields of Cambodia to the pulsating heart of Jakarta
Six hundred and forty million people you have 300 million
Muslims. Hundred twenty million Christians and fifty million Buddhists Taoist Confuciunists.
Thailand Malaysia the Philippines and Vietnam.
ASEAN is one of the world's most complex regions.
We have such huge diversity and such ability now to create business create connectivity.
ASEAN has a combined economy the size of
India's. The opportunities are massive but so are the
challenges. The importance of borders particularly our regions is spreading away.
Southeast Asia is a region at the crossroads
an emerging economic powerhouse whose future depends on how it moves forward.
Key decisions made now will affect ASEAN the next generation
Hello I'm Haslinda Amin. We begin here in Thailand where a
little over 50 years ago ASEAN was born. Five countries that
came together fearful of the advance of communist China.
A lot has changed since then .
Vietnam Myanmar and Cambodia have joined from difficult times
and the region's economies have been growing on average more
than 5 percent a year every year for the past 10 years.
Its biggest achievement is to take the most diverse corner of Planet Earth
Where  out of six hundred and forty million people you
have 300 million Muslims 120 million Christians and 150 million
Buddhists Taoist Confucionists is and in the most improbable region
of planet earth you produce peace and prosperity.
We have moved a long long way and I continue to be very optimistic.
Of course there's always the doomsay  that ASEAN hasn't moved and
hasn't gone further enough. But look at AirAsia. Look at the
inter ASEAN travel the inter ASEAN commerce that goes in our cargo
shows that we have moved a long way and I remain very very optimistic about ASEAN.
Different countries have a different stage
of financial sector development and so I think it's up to the
context of this country. But standardizations might be needed to
promote cross-border financial integration between ASEAN.
It's not so much about standardization having one ASEAN standard but I
think making sure that a domestic standard in each country is interoperable
particularly when we talk about cross-border payment activities
. This is the golden triangle. I'm in Thailand. That's Myanmar
and that's Laos. The river: the mighty Mekong which flows all the way to Vietnam.
This area infamous for its opium trade is
just one small piece of the jigsaw that is ASEAN.
The 10 member block is made up of vastly different nations from Indonesia with
the world's biggest Muslim population to tiny Brunei each with
diverse politics rules and religion.
ASEANs six hundred and forty million people account for around 9 percent of the world's
population and its combined GDP of around 2.8 trillion dollars
puts ASEAN on the same level as the UK France and India.
We have countries that are exceptionally rich like Singapore and Brunei.
And you have countries that are quite poor like Laos and Cambodia
. They belong to the same organisation. You have countries that
are incredibly big like Indonesia with 270 million people in
Singapore with five million people. But  that creates a
certain degree of complementarity among the ASEAN countries .
The cost of moving goods via customs to speed the single window
hasn't come to complete fruition yet. And ASEAN has to sort
itself out there quickly otherwise the likes of China and India
will dominate. E-commerce will dominate trade flows.
Is there a sense that ASEAN nations are competing against each other more
than the cooperating. I think that's a real
question and the real answer is yes.
But you see it in China a little bit as well. You'll get one
province trying to compete with another right. That rivalry
exists obviously in ASEAN it's national. So it's a little bit more.
One of the key milestones of the group has been the
creation of the ASEAN economic community set up in 2015.
the AECs end goal is to create a single market which is fully integrated into the global economy.
For treating goods it is
effectively a single market. And what we need to work on
further is that there are still some areas of long term barriers
which need to be managed. But I've been working on the
AEC for many many years for at least 20 years well when we were
negotiating the details of this agreement and when I look back
over this 20 years I must say that I'm quite pleased with what
it has achieved. It's always a question of whether you regard it
as a cup half full or a cup half empty. And I would say that it's
more than half full from where we started.
I'd like to see a common market. I would love to see freedom of movement of labour.
That might be a step too far in 10 years. But if I can
get a common market. If I can get common ownership.
Why can't AirAsia own 100 percent of all our airlines in ASEAN
ASEAN should benefit the citizens of ASEAN in various dimensions.
Financial integration. Economic integration. Trade integration. You've
been to have a common policy towards economic sustainability .
The importance of  borders, particularly in our regions
is fading away
At this time of year a huge haze blankets large parts of northern Thailand Myanmar and Laos.
Farmers are burning off
their fields clearing land after the harvest that produce packed
away in small rice meals like these. Connecting SMEs to the
fourth industrial revolution is one of ASEANs greatest challenges .
The costs of financial services is coming down dramatically for
fintech and traditional technology. We are not only able to
provide those banking services insurance services to many more
people but also to people in remote areas because what what is
important now is to have  a smart mobile phone and that
is changing the shape of financial services.
This is the secret genius of ASEAN. ASEAN is the most imperfect organisation
in the world. In fact when you watch ASEAN in slow motion it
takes two steps forward one step back one step aside
It's like a crab going around in circles right. But you slice ASEAN
decade by decade it keeps growing stronger and stronger. And
one of the reasons is that ASEAN is very flexible.
So the consensus principle is a very good principle to have because it's very flexible.
It's hard to believe that 440 million
people in ASEAN do not have bank accounts. That's next. As we
continue to explore ASEAN the next generation
Welcome back. Much of Southeast Asia has been built on small
businesses like these in some economies SMEs account for
as much as 90 percent of the jobs. But despite that the number
of unbanked remains huge 440 million people. That's a combined
population of the US and Germany put together.
People often talk about tapping the unbanked but so far that's been quite
difficult. In fact they've been targeting mainly under banked .
What are the challenges
The different dimensions. When you talk about tapping
unbanked or people who are under served we have to have a clear policy
with respect to the types of products and the types of segments
that you want to promote. For instance in Thailand we have had
very high household debt and it could be a certain segments of
the populations that are well indebted. So we need to promote
fintech together with responsible lending policies to make sure
that they get better service at a more reasonable cost using
new technology and not contributing to more
problems that would lead to financial fragilities for them.
I think the rating agency type
good credibly rule the credit guarantee program as the solution
could also be ways how to help support financial access
to the SME. At the same time I think the issue to
financial solutions could also be for SMEs to have
greater access to the financial
pool because the better information accuracy so that they have acces.
Different countries have different stages of
financial inclusion. For Thailand the access to bank deposit
account is not lower than usual market standards.
but we have more concerns about
cross-border payment transaction. I mean the cost for
cross-border payment transactions in and out of Thailand is
among the highest in the world. So we want to address that and
fintech can come in and and you know providing new types of
technology. Cut out the middleman and allowing new players to
come into this market
for the traders of Myanmar to the rice farmers of Cambodia
for businesses in Hanoi, Manila, Jakarta, Bangkok, Fintech is forging a
whole new future. But the key words keep coming back
sustainability, connectivity and inclusion.
How do you ensure that countries like Cambodia like Vietnam are not left behind .
Well first I say that Vietnam has made tremendous progress.
When we launched the Inclusive Growth program
the special consideration for Cambodia allows, and Myanmar,
to access infrastructure funding for instance at a better rate. So
those are particular initiatives we need to do. They're also
special considerations for training and retraining of workers
often providing technical vocational training. So those are
important practical measures. And because of the cost structure
of these economies are still lower than the other ASEAN members
Some investors do find them attractive.
As a company Air Asia has embraced digital with the onslaught of the Fourth Industrial Revolution.
How prepared is the region for what's to come .
Well I think we're a bit behind but boy we're catching up.
I mean if you look at the fact that the tech unicorns in Indonesia
or the usage of Viber in Philippines or Line in Thailand and the
growing amount of e-commerce and the growing amount of
connectivity through mobile phones and applications is not far behind.
The thing that I keep telling people is you need scale
right you need scale. And so ASEAN in the tech world needs to
have scale. I don't think we're far behind. I think education
has to catch up a bit. I think we need to reskill people in that
human capital. But I've always been one that ASEAN adapts
very quickly as soon as they see the opportunity will adapt .
But I think we have an opportunity to leapfrog if we can adapt a few things.
I think the integration among the neighboring among
the ASEAN members have been very significant and it has been
possible with the AEC in 2015. And that has led to significant
change in the GDP growth from the about twelve hundred
per capita income two decades ago now to about  4300
U.S. dollar per capita income which is quite significant
In terms of financial integration. How difficult is that given
that the 10 member nations are all at different stages of development.
Actually because of different stages of development
they are complementary to each other in certain countries like
Singapore, Malaysia, Thailand for example we are in excess and other
countries are also in the need of money so I think we can support
each other in that we are complementary to each other .
Definitely fintech can improve productivity in all the ASEAN countries
financial systems in ASEAN have big room for improvement. And
technology can play a big role. Fintech can also help enhance
financial inclusion but in the region because you know that the
cost of servicing different segments of the people will be
coming down substantially. You're seeing fintech.
So 10 nations different cultures languages and religions all at different
stages of development. But is there an ASEAN identity. We'll
explore that next in ASEAN. The next generation
ASEAN in his first 50 years has been a government of government project.
It's governments through government cooperation.
Now you've got to create a greater sense of ownership of ASEAN
among the people of ASEAN. And here I am glad that the ASEAN
countries have copied the European Union practice. So when you
go to London and you go to any ASEAN mission they have the
national flag and the ASEAN flag.
is there an ASEAN identity and a lot of people I have interviewed have been pretty
divided and whether there is one.
- No I don't think there is and  I'm an ASEANist. I've been promoting this word,
- Why not?
, for a long time. Well I think what is ASEAN mean to the common man that ASEAN
needs to work harder at the brand and identity. There's ASEAN
affect the common man probably the common man on the streets .
sees ASEAN more as a threat than an opportunity.
in terms of the ASEAN identity. There's a lot of work that is going on as well on
ISE identity. There's a lot of work that is going on as well on
the social and cultural aspects that runs in parallel with our
effort. Financial integration economy integration.
But as trade and investments increase as tourism increase I think we
will see a far better understanding and appreciation of each other in ASEAN.
Is there an ASEAN identity?
In many sense. Yes we are 600 million people. With a diverse language
culture and identities. But on the other hand in general we are
relatively easy going people. And I think this is an
advantage of how we could work well together.
It's not just identity mobility across borders. It's one of ASEANs biggest
challenges. Labour goods and the flow of money here people come
across the border from Myanmar every day to work and trade in
Thailand but often in ASEAN borders represent barriers to business.
We have for instance you know more than 3 million
Myanmar workers in Thailand. But it's very costly for them to
transfer money back to Myanmar. We have a lot of traders
that do border trades. Very expensive for them to receive money
and also to pay money to countries along the border. So in a
fintech can help and come in and improve financial inclusion in this aspect in a big way.
One of the issues is Labor crossing
borders. How do we resolve that issue. How can we have standardization.
That is a sensitive issue because the free
flow of labor is not on the cards because you would have
different levels of readiness for debt for a greater exchange of
people at certain levels. You see professionals for
instance and that is being pursued. The labor markets are at
different stages of development across ASEAN
and what is important is for us to focus on how we can integrate economies
through trading goods through services through investments.
And if we are able to generate good growth across different parts of ASEAN
the people in each country will have suitable jobs to have good jobs.
The other thing that we have. we work with
central banks in the regions and have seen very good progress
on promotion of usage of local currencies for trade and
investment. Two years ago we started between the Bank of Thailand
and the Bank Negara Malaysia to promote the use of Thai-Baht and Malaysian Ringgit  for trade and investment activities
Last year Bank Indonesia joined in so we had a three party arrangement. And this will help
narrow down the foreign exchange spread between the
local currencies and also provide choices for
business people in the regions to minimise their foreign exchange rate.
Depending on where you live in ASEAN the bloc's
future looks very different for the big companies and the big
cities is not only access across ASEAN borders but also to the
global market for the tens of millions of small to medium
enterprises its access to any markets. Workers want to get work
where they can and parents want to educate their children .
There is a reason ASEAN is known as one of the most diverse and complex regions in the world.
Minister your vision of ASEAN for the future.
Well I think we hope that ASEAN remains
safe prosperous and pleased. And for each week we can each
improve the well-being of people living in ASEAN. All this work
that we are doing on economy integration financial integration
on promoting fintech and so on ultimately has one simple aim
which is to improve the wellbeing of our people in ASEAN. And
with that I think we can maintain peace and
stability in ASEAN. We contribute to the global peace and prosperity.
I think we need respect that we are seeing in the
Western countries. We receive more ASEAN with greater wealth
generated so there will be more demand and diversity greater
segmentation and certain areas like the wealth management
poverty will increasingly be significant and important.
I think ASEAN should realise within itself what are the strengths and what are
the weaknesses. Some countries obviously have very strong
ability to do certain things and other countries have a
different. Singapore is never going to be an agricultural giant
. It's never going to do but it has very strong financial
infrastructure. So I think each country should not try and
replicate everything but see where they have the niche.
We have a lot more economic activities. We have a lot more common
problems that we have to deal with it and technology will
basically blur the boundaries across countries.
So we have to think more in terms of creating win-win
opportunities in our ASEAN integration framework to promote
growth and to promote sustainable prosperity for ASEAN citizens.
I think ASEAN should be much more careful and pragmatic so there be
controlled flows of labour and already if I'm not mistaken
millions of Indonesians work in Malaysia, Singapore has got
1.7 million foreigners working in this small island city
state of Singapore Thailand gets a lot of workers from Myanmar
coming in. So there is steady movement of labour but there'll
never be a kind of the kind of freedom of movement that you have
for example with the European Union. My dream for ASEAN is
that it will continue to stay together and not break apart as a
result of US China rivalry because there's one thing that keeps me
awake at night. It's worrying about how ASEAN will survive this
incredibly intense U.S. China rivalry that is coming in the next 10 to 20 years.
From source the ocean the Mekong River flows for
more than 4000 kilometers the main artery that for centuries
connected this part of the world. But times are changing fast .
Massive infrastructure projects and the digital revolution are
creating a whole new future. Thanks for watching. ASEAN: The Next Generation